GOOD JOB.
THANKS FOR BEING WITH US.
JOINING US NOW, FORMER SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE, NEWT GINGRICH IS
WITH US.
ONE THING THAT PUZZLED ME.
YOU SAID SOMETHING THAT EVERY
MODEL YOU'VE KNOWN HAS BEEN
THROWN OFF THIS ELECTION.
WE WEREN'T SUPPOSED TO PICK UP
SEATS IN 2020.
WE PICKED UP 16, I THINK, IN
2020.
NOBODY EXPECTED THAT.
HERE REPUBLICANS WIN THE 0
POPULAR VOTE BY ABOUT FIVE
MILLION VOTES AND PICKING UP
FEWER THAN EVERYBODY THOUGHT BUT
STILL GETTING A MAJORITY.
YOUR THOUGHT.
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, THE
DEMOCRATS WERE BRILLIANT AT
TARGETING WHERE TO PUT
RESOURCES.
I TALKED TWO DAYS AGO WITH ADAM
LAXALT WHO SAID, YOU KNOW, HE
WAS AHEAD AND MATCHING THE
DEMOCRAT WITH ADVERTISING UNTIL
TWO WEEKS AGO.
SUDDENLY PEOPLE DECIDED HE WON,
SO THEY CUT OFF HIS MONEY.
SHE OUTSPEND HIM THREE TO ONE
THE LAST THREE WEEKS.
LOOK AT SOME OF THESE KEY
PLACES.
IN THE CASE OF BOLDUC, MITCH
McCONNELL RAN MONEY THAT
PERMANENTLY MADE IT HARDER FOR
HIM TO 1.
SOME OF THIS IS ONE RACE AT A
TIME.
THE BIGGER STORY, KEVIN McCARTHY
RECRUITED NEW PEOPLE, THIS WILL
BE THE MOST DIVERSE HOUSE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IN HISTORY.
THE MOST WOMEN.
THE MOST VETERANS.
THE MOST MINORITIES.
AND IN FACT IF WE HAD KEPT OUR
INCUMBENTS IN 94 WHEN WE WON AND
IN 2020 WHEN KEVIN PICKED UP 16
SEATS, WE DIDN'T LOSE A SINGLE
INCUMBENT.
IF THAT WERE THE CASE NOW, WE
WOULD BE CLOSER TO 230.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS WE HAVE TO
DO IS GO BACK AND LOOK AT WHY
DID CERTAIN INCUMBENTS LOSE.
WHAT WAS HAPPENING THERE.
WHAT I'VE SEEN TONIGHT, YOU
KNOW, AND WE WERE WITH KEVIN ON
ELECTION NIGHT.
I HAD BEEN CAMPAIGNING HIM FOR
THREE DAYS, GETTING A FEEL FOR
WHAT'S GOING ON, WE WERE ALL IN
A STAKE OF SHOCK.
WE ALL THOUGHT AS YOU POINTED
OUT, WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
GENERIC BALLOT, WHEN YOU LOOK AT
FLORIDA AND NEW YORK, RETURNING
HUGE MAJORITIES, YOU HAD A SENSE
IT WAS GOING TO BE A GREAT
NIGHT.
BUT IT WASN'T.
I GOT CURIOUS ABOUT THIS.
KEVIN IS GOING TO BE SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN 218 AND 224.
THERE HAVE BEEN SEVEN CONGRESSES
SINCE 1916 IN WHICH THE MARCH
YOU'RETY WAS IN THE 220 TO 223,
WHICH INCLUDING PELOSI'S LAST
MAJORITY.
KEVIN WON'T BE FACED WITH
SOMETHING UNPRECEDENTED.
DENNY HASTERT WAS AT 221 IN ONE
ELECTION.
SO YOU CAN GOVERN WITH A PRETTY
NARROW MAJORITY.
IT'S CHALLENGING.
IT'S EXHAUSTING, TRICKY.
IT CAN BE DONE.
I THINK THE REPUBLICANS ARE
GOING TO BE IN CHARGE AND AS YOU
KNOW, PASSING OVER THAT GAVEL
FROM PELOSI TO McCARTHY IS AN
ENORMOUS SHIFT IN THE BALANCE OF
POWER IN WASHINGTON.
>> Sean: IT CAN.
YOU CANNOT OVERSTATE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS.
YOU REALLY CAN'T.
IT IS THAT BIG.
LOOK, I UNDERSTAND PEOPLE LOOKED
AT HISTORICALLY A PRESIDENT'S
FIRST TERM ENDS WITH LOSS IN
CONGRESS AND IN THIS CASE IT
TURNED OVER THE HOUSE.
I CAN -- I NEVER UNDERSTOOD -- I
LOOK AT EVERY ONE OF THESE
SENATE RACES.
I SAID, YOU KNOW WHAT?
THESE ARE ALL TOSS-UP STATES.
THESE ARE ALL HARD TO WIN.
YOU HAVE TO RUN THE TABLE ON
THESE.
I'M SEEING WHAT I CALL
ACCELERATED MIGRATION,
ACCELERATED BY COVID.
SHUT DOWNS AND PARENTS WANTING
THEIR KIDS TO HAVE IN-CLASS
LEARNING AND THE MASS EXODUS TO
THE CAROLINA, TENNESSEE AND
FLORIDA, TEXAS.
I'M LOOKING AT THAT AND I'M
THINKING, THERE'S A LOT TO BE
LEARNED HERE.
THE SAD PART IS THE RED STATES
WILL BE REDDER BUT THE TOSS-UP
STATES WILL BE HARDER FOR
REPUBLICANS TO WIN THE
PRESIDENCY.
WE HAVE ABOUT 30 SECOND.
>> YEAH, I DON'T KNOW IF THAT IS
TRUE.
IN THE END, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
OUTWEIGH ANY KIND OF GEOGRAPHIC
LINE.
WE'RE GAINING WITH LATINOS AND
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND ASIAN
AMERICANS.
TWO MORE YEARS OF BIDE